[Applauso]
[Musica]
quando una persona subisce un infortunio
va dal dottore il dottore prende in cura
alla persona che diventa un paziente il
paziente guarisce grazie alle cure del
dottore
il protagonista di questa storia sembra
essere
il dottore il termine paziente
suggerisce quasi un atteggiamento
passivo di qualcuno che aspetta di
essere curato o riparato aspetta
pazientemente di guarire
c'è però un'altra versione della storia
possibile una versione nella quale i
pazienti si riappropiano della loro
guarigione
perché un dottore non cura un paziente
ma mette il paziente in condizione di
guarire che è una cosa diversa
il vero protagonista di questa storia
è il paziente
nel 2003 avevo 29 anni e facevo ancora
sport in modo serio
Da buon milanese che sport facevo
vela Ovviamente
chi è che non conosce il famoso
lungomare di Milano dai
fu una leggerezza alla guida a fermarmi
uno di quegli incidenti che ti fanno
passare per la rianimazione per sei mesi
in un letto per due anni e mezzo di
stampelle per otto anni di ricostruzione
ossea
da atleta professionista
a paziente e professionista
in pochi secondi netti
ricorda assoluto Provinciale
Modestamente
quando quando
ripresi a conoscenza
del letto gli accorsi di una cosa
singolare la mia gamba destra era
sensibilmente più corta di quella
sinistra e aveva la tendenza virale
verso l'interno di circa 30 gradi
per qualunque sforzo io facessi e non
riuscivo a muoverla di un millimetro
Inoltre lungo il femore c'è un simpatico
braccio metallico che sembrava tenere la
gamba attaccata al resto del corpo
in quel momento capii che una pomata
antinfiammatoria non sarebbe bastata
realisticamente per farmi riprendere
dalla botta
bloccato nel letto Chiamai il primario e
chiesi Rumi e lui
Ma sì ma dai allievi Cosa vuole dire sì
la gamba è un po' più corta ma lei è
giovane al massimo zoppicherà un po'
tu sarai mica un problema
Non sarà mica un problema
Ecco questo è un medico leggero
ma di una leggerezza che un paziente non
ha voglia di sentire perché c'è una
leggerezza buona
e c'è una leggerezza che invece è fuori
luogo
Io in quel momento capii che se volevo
venirne fuori dovevo uno cambiare
ospedale
2 cercare aiuto perché da solo non ce
l'avrei mai fatta
è un atleta
che non pensa di farcela non ce la farà
mai
ero nel letto da più di un mese li avevo
cambiato ospedale Quando nella mia
stanza entra lui il prof
si siede a fianco a me
è già un dottore che si siede non è
banale Credetemi mi guarda con una con
un sorriso benevolo e mi fa
Walter sa il mio nome
Raccontami
io gli racconto di me il racconto
dell'incidente lui mi ascolta con
attenzione
Guarda la mia gamba guarda le mie lastre
e poi mi fa
Walter ci vorrà del tempo ma secondo me
puoi tornare a correre
il mio uomo
io avevo bisogno
avevo bisogno di sentirmi dire quello
avevo bisogno di fiducia
e di un obiettivo che mi motivasse
ora sapevo che sarei potuto tornare a
fare quello che era la mia vera passione
un altro sport classico dei milanesi
ma ha un atleta Un allenatore un
obiettivo motivante è la fiducia non
bastano ha bisogno di uno staff che lo
segue durante tutto il suo percorso e
allora parte la mia ricerca con un
solido approccio
empirico a prova ed errore L'esperienza
di atleta mi aveva insegnato che
un infortunio spesso può avere più
concause e che se noi interveniamo su
più fronti contemporaneamente
questi si possono potenziare a vicenda
quando ero giovane in seguito a un salto
giocando a pallacanestro e li capì
subito che non era il mio sport per
tantissimi motivi
mi venne il mal di schiena un forte mal
di schiena mio padre Allora decise di
portarmi da un ortopedico il quale mi
disse lapidario Qui ci vuole il busto
a 16 anni
Poi farà una gara per uscire con me col
busto
fortunatamente mio padre che non amava
particolarmente i dottori era scettico
sul busto e allora decise di portarmi
dal suo chiropratico Jean Pierre dovete
sapere che in quegli anni la
chiropratica magari ora si conosce un
po' di più ma all'epoca era una
disciplina semisconosciuta
Io mi ricordo Quando entrai nello studio
di Jean Pierre ero molto curioso perché
non ne sapevo nulla Neanche io lui mi
fece entrare mese di fronte a uno
specchio
dietro un filo a piombo come quelli dei
cantieri
mi fa camminare mi fa alcuni test motori
e poi mi fa
Walter
il mal di schiena
probabilmente causato dalla masticazione
Vai a limare i denti qui e qui e poi
torna da me
vedrai che mal di schiena passerà
Ovvio la prossima volta che ho le
emorroidi vado dall'oculista ho detto io
e invece feci come suggerito da
Giampiero Andai dal dentista il quale
confermò il mio problema di masticazione
i denti qui e qui tornai da Jean Pierre
due scroccata la schiena e il mal di
schiena passò lì compresi le basi di uno
specifico approccio alla cura
un approccio per il quale un problema
non viene solo osservato nel punto in
cui si manifesta Ma viene osservato
all'interno di tutto il sistema in cui
si manifesta Questo si chiama approccio
sistemico perché se un atleta gioca male
una partita non è detto che il motivo
sia legato strettamente all'allenamento
o al gioco magari gli è morto il piccolo
bonsai che teneva in salotto regalo
della mamma lontana e lui era molto
triste semplicemente
è meglio diffidare di coloro che ci
dicono che la loro è l'unica soluzione
possibile soprattutto quando ci hanno
ascoltato per tre minuti in realtà noi
non ci siamo neanche sentiti ascoltati
Perché alcuni dottori alcuni
sono un po' leggeri a volte nelle loro
diagnosi noi siamo un sistema complesso
e come ogni sistema complesso ricercare
un preciso percorso di causa effetto è
molto difficile quindi è meglio
ricercare più strade e trovare i dottori
che abbiano voglia di ascoltarci e
magari anche di collaborare fra loro
Ma tutto questo ha un atleta ancora non
basta non basta
l'allenatore l'obiettivo motivante la
fiducia l'approccio sistemico lo staff
Manca ancora una cosa che è molto
importante
perché un atleta ha bisogno intorno a sé
di persone che gli alleggeriscano il
peso della gara
che lo sostengano
la leggerezza è data a volte anche da
cose molto semplici come tua moglie che
ti porta a letto il caffè dopo che tu
hai terminato una complicata piuttosto
dolorosa e lunga medicazione alla tua
gamba o con un amico che ti regala la
sua personale collezione di fumetti
perché sai che tu ne avrai più bisogno
di lui
dei mesi che verranno
serve una leggerezza buona serve
circondarsi di persone che abbiano
voglia di stare con noi di alleggerirsi
il peso e che credano nella nostra
guarigione almeno quanto ci crediamo noi
da questa esperienza
ne è nata una formula
la formula del paziente che contiene
tutti gli ingredienti affinché i
pazienti tornino essere i protagonisti
della loro storia
la formula si chiama così
fionda
f come fiducia una fiducia incrollabile
che alla fine
otterrai il tuo obiettivo di guarigione
qualunque esso sia
e
come impegno costante perché per
ottenere quell'obiettivo potrebbe
volerci molto tempo e molta pazienza
Eh come obiettivo motivante
che tenga alta la volontà di far fatica
perché di fatica se ne fa
de
come dottori chi siano
al contempo Preparati anche leggeri
di una leggerezza buona e che abbiano
voglia di ascoltarci
Ah Come approccio sistemico per poter
affrontare il problema da più parti e in
più modi che si sostengono a vicenda
ora
i più attenti fra voi
si saranno accorti
amo Non l'ho fatto apposta Ti ho
lasciato una lettera la n
la n sta per
crema spalmabile alla nocciola che però
non posso nominare per motivi di
copyright
[Applauso]
perché se da un lato
per un paziente
è giusto affrontare l'infortunio come
come
un atleta professionista dall'altro
dobbiamo evitare di prenderci troppo sul
serio e ogni tanto concederci qualcosa
di piacevole
una fionda che aiuti i pazienti
a liberarsi del peso dell'infortunio e a
tornare a vivere
con leggerezza
[Applauso]